thank you hey
lucy hey say hey how you doing good how
are you i'm really good i'm excited to
do this me too yeah we're going to talk
about what that tattoos of you
of me
you were like don't get a tattoo
you're like you can do anything just
don't get a tattoo
i listen to him
[Music]
that that's great pizza danny devito no
it's it's it's dorito right oh dorito
danny dorito
your hair is really long in it and yeah
kind of look like puppy dog it's great
you know that the hair looks like ears
like a little cocker spaniel yeah
and my head comes to a point
[Music]
i have a friend who has me in his phone
as lucy burrito burrito's a good idea oh
yeah danny burrito the two of us yeah
sure yeah after little demons yeah sure
okay yeah then you guys can see the show
first and then decide but like once you
see it you're gonna want
a burrito yeah august 25th at 10 o'clock
[Music]
yeah hello
ongo gablogian the art collector charmed
i'm sure
i love that wig
i love doing it wish i had the garb
right now you know what you kind of look
like aunt gigi i do look like my sister
yeah and she's my sister angie yeah yeah
exactly yeah she had bleached long hair
and uh she wore those big the glasses
but she was not derivative you know she
was very one of a kind yeah
[Music]
oh that is angie yeah that is andrew
that's my sister yeah that right there
i swear to god i look exactly like her
with the flowers i like the flowers it's
the whole
and the hair is pinkish and i'm not
afraid to wear those flowers no i like i
can wear those flowers springtime that
character was
so much fun to do when you're working on
something and you put on the clothing
you know you can even rehearsal like in
civvies and stuff regular clothes all of
a sudden you stick a jacket on or a hat
or a like a wig or like that you know
the whole ensemble kind of like kicks
you into gear and it's a lot of fun and
i understand why
people would want to get these tattoos
because you'd look down at it and you'd
be like
life life's silly let's bring that into
our daily lives absolutely yeah we need
more silliness yeah we do
that's very nice oh it's on the foot
it's on her the bottom of the bottom of
her foot oh
danny defeat
lorax has never had such a smile in his
life yeah yeah
yeah you could do that yeah so we read
all the dr seuss books and then when he
was the voice of the lorax i was a
little bit beyond those childhood days
you know but i still appreciate it it
was a lot of fun it was cool yeah it's a
great movie
to get the oil or the something i need
some kind of fuel the feet up by the
mouth i don't know is that a foot in the
claw yeah that doesn't
no it's two feet right you got a knife
in your mouth it's a toe knife i believe
oh a toenail oh a dog
jesus christ frank are you cutting your
toenails with a steak knife i suppose
you have a problem with that too ah oh
oh
botched toe i botched that one oh that's
a botched job that's bleeding i need
some trash to plug up the cut that's
smart yeah and that's on someone's calf
you don't have to see it oh that's like
a surprise these are all great yeah
yeah let me see some more
oh
seriously well seriously
is that seriously on a foot and one oh
my
god
and what a foot i love that foot there's
a hint of like oswald in there oh yeah
totally there's a little cobble pot in
that that too yeah which i like a lot
like it's bringing me back to when you
were um the penguin and you had to get
the black acrylic nails put on he would
come home with them just these three
let's see uh what i'd like to do first
is to put these little glove thingies on
you our research tells us that voters
like fingers
so if we want to just lose this
we'll do it another time then yeah
i was i was young i was i was a child
and i remember you taking my hand
and i just gone stop it
no
i'll uh talk to you when you're um when
you're done playing this role
don't keep any of the penguin props i i
kept the whole penguin like i got me not
a penguin real i mean the whole the
statue and like the no the everything
the hat the oh everything i kept a
replica we have um we have quite a
storage uh
a large actual life-size
penguin and then there's the mold
of the penguin and that'll scare the
[ __ ] out of you
once i glom onto it i wasn't going to
give it back yeah absolutely not warner
brothers
come and get it
bye
oh wow
that is delicious oh there's a rummage
from him i'm a ham this is ham
soaked in rum it is loaded with booze
god damn it frank eating your drinks
that is genius how i'm a rum ham rum ham
i love it you should get one of those
hats does that look warm yeah it looks
cozy it's cozy right yeah watch tv
really cool one of those on and watch tv
yeah and you look really happy
it looks good
too tasty
holy oh wow
wow that's really ham you also kind of
look like john lovitz i do a little bit
yeah is there a little pavarotti yeah
i love that ham everybody likes the rum
ham i i've tried it it's it's great you
can make it there are recipes online for
rum ham you gotta soak it good
[Music]
this is oh there's the troll troll
yeah you got to play the troll
get in this boy's hole you got to pay
the trolls to get in
yeah i mean we'll have to get them to
come on we'll get them to be on little
demon my friends came up with the idea
we figured it was um a great idea for an
animated show you know it's about uh the
antichrist and satan and
they go through metaphysical realms we
blow things up yeah lucy's brother
my son jake is producing it and so it
was a family kind of thing
oh dog you know oh dr toboggan oh yes i
got the stethoscope yeah i am a doctor
dr toboggan
i see it now and uh where's my uh
string of condoms
not in there whoops so
i dropped my monster condom that i used
for my magnum dong they left out the
string of condoms i see that that's on a
thigh
and that's bold but you know summer
comes around you want to show it off man
then it's beautiful you know it gets
hotter it's got great colors another
color because i got a nice pretty smiley
face yeah it's smiley brings joy it
brings joy and fear joy and fear
on one thigh
there you go
oh
my fire baby like my fire that's really
special look at that yeah you got
nipples mm-hmm yeah great body yeah gums
little shoes uh smells a little bit very
spelt yeah so i wonder if that's gonna
happen with little demons
i wonder if there's to be a lot of
devils and antichrists and maybe stuff
like that you're going to be all over
people lots of [ __ ] lots of wars
oh oh
danny
oh
danny devito
excellent lucy yeah i'm getting i was
i'm catching on i'm catching on to the
game guys that's really i mean that's
got to be painful to do that on your
foot yeah like that but it's nice they
like shaved to great job so that you
know they do great these artists tattoo
artists take my hat off to them